[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
sunny and and they realize it's not
really really music it's not impossible
to make music with vegetables my name is
Susanna got my ax and then I'm a member
of the vegetable orchestra the orchestra
exists since 18 years now the earth
instrument rolls the tomato because you
can do sounds with tomatoes but it will
be messy for sure
we go shopping on the market first we
choose all the vegetables there we have
three kinds of instruments one is the
red innate you can just buy it at the
market and play it's like the head
horoscopes not ready already and then
there are the simple instruments like
with one cut or some cut to get it like
that then with the more complex
instruments we have some that work like
normal instruments you know the pumpkin
is the bass drum and the sound of the
pumpkin is really important good after
shopping we go to the venue and it
starts to build instrument all in all it
takes two to three hours to build all
the instruments for everybody and then
we start with the soundcheck and things
we have new instruments each time we
have to have a very long soundcheck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra so they're
really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
it soup during the building process of
the vegetables instrument with the
remaining vegetables when we serve it to
the audience after the concert and it's
also after hearing and seeing us and
smelling the vegetables which will be
intense in there because it's so small
this theater and then you can also you
never get it out of your head anymore if
you're in the orchestra to look
vegetables in another way there's a
crime detective follow the clues they
get close but then they reach the water
so they call in underwater criminal and
investigator that's Mike Barry hold on
this is Mike Barry I dive in very
strange places looking for very strange
thing mike has been an underwater
criminal investigator for 35 years how
easy is it to get rid of a murder weapon
all it is is applicable
and someone's mind that murder weapon is
forever gone if no idea there are people
like me crazy enough to go to health
care search law enforcement depends on
guys like Mike to preserve and recover
evidence your three cores in underwater
Criminal Investigation is body recovery
vehicle recovery and evidence recovery I
get called about twice a week sometimes
more sometimes less and when a call
comes in chances are Mike's in for a
challenge some of these locations are
absolutely disgusting our typical dive
site is dark it's deep it's cold full of
obstructions it's contaminated the
danger is there when you get in the
water you know I've had murders tell me
you know you'll never find
I said well we'll see go ahead number
one for diver one there's nothing like
finding the target when your hand hits
it and you feel it
and you realize you've got it for a
public safety diver there's no greater
thing and when he's out there searching
for a body I look at it as an honor
because you realize the importance of
what you're asked to do there's a family
and there's no closure until you bring
them up you know not every diver can do
this not everybody has it in their DNA
it's what I was meant to do I couldn't
think of anything better to do with my
life truth is I can't wait for the next
call to help someone in some way either
to bring closure or to bring a
conviction
[Music]
I cook for warthogs EMU lions tigers
hyenas Spoonbill Sunbear Lemang go and
drag they can be very picky
every morning I am preparing around 350
pounds of food
my name is Fifi Kyle's and I prepare the
food for the animals at the Oakland Zoo
I'm also known as physician my day
starts off very early before the Sun
even comes up I've got to get the food
for the animals or we have nothing to
prepare the calm before the storm of
getting to the market I need to get
about a ton of food today literally the
produce market is kind of hectic you've
got a lot of forklifts running back and
forth you got books everywhere there's a
lot to choose from I have to say
organized or this can get very
overwhelming I've got a huge market that
I've got to go through I've got to pick
out the right produce so the limited
amount of time at the market because I
have to get back here to prepare the
diet I open the door to the kitchen and
then I know my day is truly begun
[Music]
Sun bears 48 grams Apple Kawada Monday
three hard-boiled eggs line half 10 boom
and when I hit the brakes off the line
seven serving who hold my heresy grams
restriction one draw vermin vitamin 44
grand my banana LoCascio rented actually
four grams we follow in the zoo itself
as a whole prepares about a thousand
diets a day so that's anywhere from the
elephant's down to the leaf cutter ants
and all the little reptiles and all the
little frogs it's important that we get
the diets right because the animals
can't send the food back they can't tell
us oh I don't like this
we don't take days off everything still
has to happen the food gets prepared
exactly the same way every single day
I tried killing most Christmas wants
they don't pay attention usually people
first see the mannequin the kind of
wandering deal what does it do what's
the purpose of it it has mouth it has
teeth that have got gums
they had a cheek we could sell we got
the same haircut as well my name is
Philip realice I am the director of
sales for columbia dental phone
we supply dental mannequins to dental
school we basically supplies that first
patient whether the train on before they
actually will want to like
the company started in 1917 so next year
Columbia gallon will be a hundred years
old the models the mannequins are all
assembled by hand
he saw well over a million people a year
and we make a variety of models we
provide models of retardo and the teeth
we make models that have a variety of
disease under the gums on the guns if
they need to they could do a narrow root
canal on the dog and cat as well we have
models that have absolutely no teeth at
all so they can learn how to do a
complete denture the reason why this
actually looks this way we really didn't
want to put any gender in the mannequin
so it could be anybody
the design of it is based on an order
average human would look like as far as
the size of the head the ears the mouth
opening the softest of the gum tissue
the only thing that doesn't suddenly is
maybe the bad breath but other than that
it's a great patient because it just
cooperates with you I've been with the
company for 41 years I have no idea that
I'll be working with dental mannequins
at all all these piece my granddaughters
think I worked for the tooth fairy and
so that really works out well because
it's the parents that get to put money
under the pillow for to bill tell mom
they took their grandpa
he knows all he knows the tooth fairy
a lot of people consider mini-golf to be
very benign and all fun and games but at
this level it can be a cutthroat
competition among the greatest players
in the world
[Music]
my name is Matt mail I'm a professional
mini golfer I was a regular golfer ever
since childhood I started up at about
eight years old
and cutting was always the greatest
facet of my game the idea of doing
nothing but putting for 18 holes
instantly appealed to me and I just
began practicing a lot people don't
realize that mini-golf is a highly
precise sport improvement can come very
tediously to be competitive it really
requires an extensive mapping of each
hole and we can be out here for up to 10
hours a day or so for several days
before a tournament when I first arrived
at a course I diagnosed the hole I want
to come up with a clear plan of attack
on each hole and then just it's a matter
of repetition from there we are at the
2016 mini-golf Masters in North Myrtle
Beach South Carolina this tournament is
the premier event each year in mini golf
it draws players from all over the world
the green jacket is the most coveted
prize in mini-golf the competition is
very fierce the players here are the
best of the best and it's an immense
challenge because even a stretch of five
bad minutes or 10 bad minutes can
disqualify you from contention just a
tiny miscue here or there can spell
major disaster on one hole I really do
have an authentic admiration of what the
winner had to do to perform under the
pressure of such a major tournament
because
I know from experience how hard it is
many golf's not a sport for everyone
there's constant frustration there's
constant adversity it it rewards
patience and it rewards determination
and it never gets old to see the ball go
on the hole I don't think that thrill
will ever go away
[Music]